i tell you i mean you're always you
never take these things for granted i
mean
some you just don't and um
i think uh obviously you know i've won
two acm entertainer of the years and
and you know i mean there's been some
years i thought i've might have should
have won another one and i didn't so
um i think you kind of tell yourself
well maybe you're done winning them and
then
to win another one is uh you know
is very special and you know it has been
fortunate i i had a
i had an opportunity you know to
potentially perform on the show and then
i couldn't because of the
kovi the cova diagnosis and so i'm a
little removed from being
able to be in the room and i wish so so
bad i could have been in the room but
still the the emotions are there i mean
my phone is
i mean my phone is like literally on
fire
with people calling and congratulating
so what what a special night well
certainly the key to feeling better for
obviously having coveted was
you know i was i was very fortunate to
um not have a long um
a long set of symptoms and stuff that
that uh i mean it was still quite
challenging for a couple of days
but um you know thank god for
um just certainly health and and like i
said there were times where caroline was
nursing me back to health and but um so
i was certainly amazed to to move
through that i mean and now
looking back on the past certainly going
into a year and a half
i mean the main thing that gets you
through uh that's
got us through certainly your friends
and your family and
and praying uh praying everybody
can see the other side of certainly this
pandemic and
and leaning on you know leaning on the
people in your
organization and the people that that um
put me out on the road for i mean i've
been out there touring for 16 years and
a lot of these guys and girls that are
on the road
that are on the road with me have been
there since day one
so to to make sure that they're all good
to make sure that they're all happy and
making it through this i mean it's been
an amazingly challenging year for the
entertainment business
music business and all of the satellite
companies
um that support the music and certainly
the fans so
um i think um
like i said at the core of it all the
fact that that i've been home a little
more
and i could spend quality time with my
family has certainly gotten me through
um all of the challenges of this year
but but you learned
that that at your core i mean being out
on stage in front of your fans
is a big it's a big
it's a big um part of my happiness as a
human being too
so i mean i'm not gonna sit here and say
i haven't had ups and downs and
bouts of kind of depression stuff so
um it's as so many people out there so
i'm just
uh you know you look back on a night and
certainly winning entertainer of the
year is
is certainly one of those things where
you're like you know thank you god thank
you fans and
very very excited here in l.a tonight